Nobody knows for sure what the original purpose of Stonehenge was.
Although there is no way to prove its purpose,...
...there is evidence of cremations on the site,...
...indicating at one point Stonehenge was used as a funeral site.
The generally accepted theory though, is that Stonehenge was originally used as an astronomical calendar.
The real mystery of Stonehenge, however, is not what it was used for, but how it was built.
Three types of stones are found there.
The first type has been traced to a location 13 kilometers northwest of the site.
The second and third types were 40 and 250 kilometers away, respectively.
Leading scientists and mechanical engineers cannot figure out...
...how people with no knowledge of the wheel could move these huge stones to the site.
If you were to propose this as a theoretical problem to a scientist,...
...he's likely to say, "No way" or "You've got to be kidding me".
Then just mention the word, "Stonehenge".
The scientist, if he knows anything about history, will nod his head at this,...
...for Stonehenge is an ancient feat of engineering that still confounds the greatest minds.
I'm sure that it will continue to stump scientists for centuries more.